sponsor
monster yes
finally
aimcontrollers.com baby that's right
they designed a controller it's very
premium look at that it matches it
matches my chair not only can you
customize your own design and make it
very sexy like this one but it also
feels very premium it's got all these
kinds of textures on it you know it just
feels good in your hands what can i say
what's cool about this is that you guys
are gonna be able i'm giving you this
opportunity that's right to design the
official this is just a prototype the
official
design
of the pewdiepie controller which will
be sold worldwide baby so check out the
link description for this uh web page it
works better on computer basically it's
very simple you can just upload any
picture see already this looks insanely
good you can customize the grip texture
color
you can customize the paddles in the
back but anything on this baby you can
customize so i want you guys to be
creative you can be artistic you can
make meme worthy ones you can even
change the text on the back in the front
uh and write whatever i'll write my
gamer tag i love asked too i'll pick the
winner next week so submit your designs
and again thanks aimcontrollers.com for
sponsoring this video very nice product
check it out now without further ado
let's jump into it leave your entries in
the subreddit
and i'll watch submissions in the next
episode
all right since reddit has changed now
i'm just gonna go from top to bottom
from now on instead of fighting an
indian why not become one i am not
indian by the way thank you for
clarifying i am an indian and this is on
trending here don't worry cuz we got you
just title your next video as jai hind
hail india and put the indian flag
in the thumbnail and clickbait the title
as i am half indian
watch it blow up i feel like this is a
bait
to put me in trouble
but i also think it's a great clickbait
so it cancels out all right we'll try
this out you better not be trolling me i
swear to god in case you don't know the
context
that's right this channel is at war
where i wore everybody against the
indian the indian channel t-series is
about to overtake this channel
in just the span of a few months jai
hint humility is a virtue i don't want
to be the biggest channel that is why it
must be
i'm pretty sure there's a lot of comment
a lot of channels more appropriate than
me to be number one and i'm pretty sure
it's not me and i'm pretty sure it's not
t-series okay this guy said it was his
last day
sorry
mcdonald's merch that is awesome
upgrade
i absolutely mad that
i finally made it into the y and made
pewdiepie smile
i will cherish this moment forever that
is not a smile okay i didn't smile okay
so whatever whatever moment of happiness
you got just delete it okay because it
gave me nothing
nothing he said only why he would bring
it back maybe he forgot let's remind him
again
oh yeah next week
okay we're doing the
we're doing the controller thing all
right let's do that first then the week
after we'll do the green screen okay
what is this
this is not pewdiepie lore okay
out of all things that we put in the
videos to create lore
this
this is what you're focusing
yeah okay no you got us there we have to
i get the joke but for real why does he
mirror the video it's obviously a call
for help okay i don't mirror the video
for anything it means nothing okay stop
reading into nothing
jesus the absolute mad lion gave myself
a ticket so that they will
okay this is not
worthy
of absolute man land
mad life perhaps okay i do this all the
time that's right
if you ever get a ticket just save it
and then put it on your car so you won't
get another one although it doesn't work
because they give you another one
anyways
ligma died of ninja what's new
you know he's married right
the curious case of felix shelburne late
2017 early 2018
late 20s
he's becoming part of the nine-year-old
army himself once we have defeated all
the indians and i have transformed into
a nine world myself i shall become more
powerful than you can possibly imagine
this is how we count years on the
pewdiepie channel 10 years old
nine years old plus one bonus year bonus
year that's right i am nine plus
21 bonus years damn i'm really old jesus
wait
no wait 19 19 point is here math how
does it work 19. i said 19. i said 19.
shut up the gang is all
here we are all taking a stand
against the indians on youtube t-series
must be stopped this is not just some
sort of joke okay
it's not just about me being the biggest
subscribed channel it's about doing
what's right we have mr beast on our
side
we have
we apparently jake paul is on our side
vladimir putin
all right fine kim jong-un
i didn't know he had a twitter logan
paul is on her side wow amazing thank
you
what a strong army of nine-year-olds
[Music]
petitioned to change up votes and
downvotes into brofist
and t series petition denied okay
but then australians will have brofists
as downvotes with the wedding getting
closer let's remind stop reminding me of
stuff
i say a lot of things okay stop holding
it what'd i say now oh it's this one
have to wear a full body leontard on
your wedding day or have the person you
are marrying wear the football please
guys please no
all right
you can remind me all you want the date
hasn't happened yet
i never back out on my word i'm a man of
my word i always do everything i say i
will
anyone any of y'all think mr bees should
make a video of him making 10 100 000
youtube accounts to subscribe to
pewdiepie pewdiepie subreddit wants me
to do this but
what these nine year olds don't realize
is i've been doing this all along how do
you think he became one well
do a better job then jesus christ mr b
please
amp up the pace man come on oh there it
is someone already made it for me
perfect
it looks awful but i'll take it i'll
take it scientists have developed the
first telescopic contact lens this lens
is capable of zooming your vision three
times all we asked for
was to exit youtube while playing music
oh my god
it was me on the lawn does anyone know
what happened to this channel like
they're just deleting their videos now
like why what is the reason there is an
indian conspiracy i swear it is
i don't like this
who's voting for t series
what is this
[Music]
actual footage of pewdiepie
challenging
team series since t-series is kind of
like indian vivo it doesn't count yes it
does yeah
we need to stop before it's too late
people are talking about t-series like
it will take over and i say nay indians
try again next time okay
that's it for this week's law as always
thank you guys for posting all the memes
i very much appreciate it it's always
fun i'm so proud that we have this
community and i can't wait to see
where you guys are gonna submit for the
aim controller design should we do the
highest voted one wins
i feel like that will just makes it
i don't know
yeah sure let's do that thanks for
smashing like and subscribing i'll see
you guys tomorrow with another video
[Music]
you